RON PANTOFARO: So let's go
10,000 feet up in the air
and take a look at migrations.
Right.
So migration is a journey.
And the journey
always starts with
a careful and thorough
assessment of the environments
you want to move.
All right.
And then you do what we
call cloud foundations.
Cloud foundations we mean you
start networking preparations,
you do identity
management, project
an organizational
structure, and so on.
And then there is this little
task of actually moving
your workloads into GCP.
And then you optimize.
When we say optimize, we
mean you can reduce costs.
You can improve performance.
You can leverage
managed services
or use cloud native
technologies, whatever works.
TAD EINSTEIN: So we
talked about assessment.
Ron mentioned that's
the first one.
But actually what we
want to enable you
with is prior to the assessment
before you start deploying
an assessment tool
and understand what's
in the environment,
it's really important
to understand what
your cloud strategy is.
So Google's professional
services organization
has released something known as
the GCAF, which is the Google
Cloud adoption framework.
I recommend everyone
download this.
It's a white paper.
And what it does
is it really goes
over all the major key items
that you need to focus on
as you're looking to
take your cloud journey,
everything from culture
change to making sure
that everyone has the right
skill sets, technologies,
and really helping
the business define.
And I usually say, when
I work with my customers,
I bring this usually
to the C-suite.
We're able to have some
very deep discussions.
And, really, at any level
of the organization,
it really helps you plan so that
when you go into the assessment
phase, you're going to get
what you're looking for
and you the right strategy
from a corporate standpoint.
RON PANTOFARO: And speaking
of assessment phase,
let's talk a little bit what's
happening during assessment
and discovery.
So there's enablement
and training.
Right.
JCP is a new platform.
You might need new tool
sets, new skill sets.
You might want to do
some proof of concept.
You take inventory of
applications, workloads,
servers, licenses, operating
systems, the works.
You start thinking
about costs, especially
if you move from on prem.
It's a different
financial model.
You do some dependency mappings
between the applications
and the workloads.
And then you start
thinking about how
you catalog the
applications and which
ones you're going to
move first to the cloud.
And this is an example of one
way to catalog applications.
So we got applications that
are what we call disconnected,
meaning they don't
have any dependencies.
And they're not
mission critical.
And those are relatively easy.
Then you've got to ones
that have some dependencies
but are still not mission
critical like a back office.
Gets trickier.
And then you got production
workloads, your ERP,
and your databases, and
your production apps.
And they obviously
have cross dependencies
and are mission critical.
And those get hard or
sometimes impossible to move.
TAD EINSTEIN: So when you go
through the assessment phase,
you're going to get to
learn about the two tools
that we've partnered with.
We talk about characteristics
of a good first mover.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to highlight just
a few that are critical.
So for example, a lot of
companies go into this
and they say, you
know what, if we
can move our largest
application, that's
going to be a success.
And companies do this.
I don't recommend it.
I usually recommend
you choose something
that's not business critical.
There's always a lot of
risk when you get started.
There's a lot of learning
usually on your side.
And you want to make sure
you do something that really
can be consumed and
that you reduce risk,
because at the
end of the day you
want to start proving out that
Cloud's the right move for you,
that you really understand
how to properly migrate.
And that's a good
direction to go in.
Also to highlight you don't
want to choose edge cases.
Right.
A lot of customers have that
really difficult application
and they'd like to use that.
It's not good and here's why.
When you do the
first migrations,
you want do something
that's repeatable,
because everyone
the organization
is going to be doing
this for the first time.
So you want an
application that's
very representative
of what may be
a majority or a good percentage
of your applications are.
Some other ones to really
focus on I would say
are requiring less app
refactoring and requiring
less data migration, because
you want to get a quick win.
You want to get
comfortable with the cloud.
Through one of our
tools Velostrata,
when you talk about
having a lot of data,
you don't have to worry about
it because the VM comes up
in Google Cloud as
it streams the data.
But still, nonetheless
choose something
with a small enough data
set so you can really
get that win quicker than not.
And the last one
just to highlight
is compliance challenges.
So I personally have
been in situations
where a customer says
we have the perfect app.
Everyone goes forward.
And then compliance
comes and says
this one's highly regulated
and it takes about eight months
to work through compliance.
So these are the
kinds of questions
you want to ask internally
as you're working
and also as you work
with a Google partner.
So how do we make this happen?
Well, we have four
migration partners--
Cloud Physics, StratoZone,
both of who are here today,
and also RISC Networks
and Cloudamize.
And this is really
going to give you
the tools to understand
deeply what's
in your environment
from a cost perspective
and also from a
component perspective
as well as connectivity
between those components.
So with that being
said, I'd like
to introduce Chris Grossmeier
from Cloud Physics.
CHRIS GROSSMEIER:
So Cloud Physics
is really the
first step when you
get to that level of
assessment that you
want to make that decision
to go to the cloud
or not go to the cloud.
At some point
you're going to have
to have a marker or
an indicator telling
you is this an opportunity.
So when we look at the
ecosystems of users out there,
the platform's a
little bit more broad.
IT users use this day to day.
Our pedigree started as a
vSphere administrative tool.
Great insights into
what's going on
in the virtual infrastructure,
a lot of analytics,
and right sizing,
and functionality,
really giving you meaningful use
as a vSphere admin in the data
center.
If you're a channel
partner, this
is really the next level up that
we're seeing a lot of activity.
This is that trusted
advisor, the team
or the partner that's
coming in and helping
you make that intelligent
decision to go to the cloud.
They come in.
They may offer the assessment
for you, be fully funded.
They may offer hardware
refresh, right sizing,
and other services to
help you get there.
They're really critical to
making sure that that happens.
And again, like I
said, that trusted
advisor and that collaborative
intelligence view
between the two of you.
And ultimately, this third
tier also, Google, Intel,
funding these types
of assessments
and helping you guys
make the right move.
Reference architectures,
best practices,
showing services that have
been repeatable and usable
in the past.
Combined, these are all
the channel partners
and the resources
that are bringing
these types of
assessments to market
so you don't have to feel
like you're doing this alone.
So we have multiple
use cases I'm
going to talk through
real quick here.
Getting a view of what's
going on inside my data center
is the first part
of the platform.
But what's nice is, once
we have performance data
and configuration
data, we can start
doing costing and modeling.
One of the core
functionalities of the platform
allows us to model
approximate costs of resources
and estimates of how
much does our data center
cost to operate today.
Intelligent meaning of that
value is that we can look at it
and say, is it going to
save us money or cost us
more, so this ROI and
TCO type analysis.
Getting visibility into what's
unique about on premise,
the hardware, the
resources we're
consuming, services, and
power, and things like that.
On the cloud side though,
changing up the regions,
changing storage options,
changing sizing options
and right sizing, choosing
different geographies.
We can apply all
those different costs
and give you approximations
between the two resources
as well as other
clouds if that were so
being in the assessment.
Ignore the bullets here.
I'll talk to the image.
Looks like they get
out of sync here.
For those of you that
have on premise hardware,
visibility into the
hardware and the resources
is also going to be critical.
As you start aging
out your old systems,
you're running vSphere
6.0 or maybe 5.5,
you want to make that
migration to vSphere 6.7.
There's going to be an
opportunity to do some hardware
refresh potentially.
And what you really
want to start
is looking at the story
that's relevant to this cloud
migration.
Should I replace this hardware
and bring it up to 6.7
and invest those resources,
or is there a cost avoidance
by moving to the cloud?
And having the intelligence
behind the scenes
as to the number of resources
and what potentially should
move is going to be important.
And the one that's
out of order here
that show migration
to AWS scenario.
We can actually pull in the live
feed from that EC2, CloudWatch,
your billing
resources, and start
looking at the cost
and the spend on AWS
and give you a comparison
of resources on GCP.
Looking at the instances,
identifying which
would be the ideal class.
Maybe we want to do
some right sizing
and adjust based on performance,
taking some of the waste
that we have on
the other clouds.
As we've seen typically
of resources deployed,
once it's out there, it's very
rarely adjusted or right sized,
taking those types
of intelligence
and making that compelling
story internally
for that cloud migration.
And finally some financial
and performance analysis.
There's a lot more
inside the data
center that may have an impact
on their decision to move--
storage, for example,
storage waste, resources,
and hardware refresh; licenses
and third party resources
in the data center.
How efficiently is
your team actually
managing the data as well.
Like I said, our
pedigree started off
as a vSphere admin tool.
A lot of the best
practices and resources,
patching and management.
Gaining that visibility
and understanding
how efficiently you actually
manage your data center
may be important.
You may find that you
are doing a excellent job
and you can actually keep things
on premise very efficiently
while you do the
migration, or you
may find that you are
way behind the times.
You're not doing support.
You're not doing updates.
There's a lot of security
issues out there.
Maybe it's time to
move to the cloud
and let the cloud providers
take on that risk for you.
So architecturally, quickly
address how this works.
Cloud Physics is an appliance.
We're a single virtual appliance
purview center or a connection
into the cloud provider.
And what we'll do is
we'll collect performance
and configuration metadata
from the resources
and bring it to the
cloud for analysis.
So we are a SaaS based platform.
We will continue to collect that
data at the most granular level
as possible to us, so for
the virtual infrastructure
every 20 seconds.
That 20 second
granularity is great
because we can do
a lot of histograms
and detailed analysis on that as
well as the configuration data.
We have a shared portal
view of it as well.
So once it comes down,
the partners and you
can work together and
collaborate on that data.
And we're very non-intrusive.
The only thing we need to talk
to in the virtual environment
is resources like the
managers like the vCenter.
We do not have to
touch the hosts.
touch the guests.
We are not using an agent.
Everything we do is directly
through the VMWare APIs
and they actually do the
resource collection for us,
so no extra load on
the infrastructure
and pulling that data in.
Since we are only
looking predominately
at metadata, performance
configuration,
we don't have to look
into the operating system.
There's no reason to go
in there unless you're
doing an application discovery,
an application dependency.
That would be the only
reason you'd set up it.
But, if you're in a high
security or highly critical
environment, we can
restrict that access
and just let the
clients do its activity.
Takes about five
minutes to deploy.
It's quick and
easy to get going.
Once it's up and
running, we have
data in the portal
within 15 minutes.
Like I said, we
collect that data
on that 20 second granularity
and we let it keep running.
So the duration of
your assessment.
So if you're doing
an assessment today,
tomorrow, for seven days,
we see the highs and lows
over the course of that week.
We know what the
weekend activity is.
Nice thing is this appliance
can keep running forever.
You can use the
platform and the portal
as a vSphere
administrative tool.
You can stage your
migrations over time,
look at trends and
usage activity, peaks,
99 to 95th percentiles, means
and averages of utilization
of all the resources as well.
Architecturally, the data that
we're collecting predominately
is configuration data for
all the resources in the data
center-- network, storage,
compute, your clusters
and hosts and the details that
are there as well in the VMs.
And we collect the
performance metadata--
CPU, memory, bandwidth,
storage, I/O utilizations.
We do this for both on
premise and for the cloud
side of the activity.
Now, it's great because,
once we have this data,
we can look at configurations
and make recommendations
for moving resources from
cloud to cloud very quickly.
And we can also look at
right sizing and performance
characteristics.
Maybe this resource would be
better off on something else.
Maybe we can consolidate
multiple lease resources down
to a single entity,
reducing the number
of instances in the cloud.
All that data comes in to us.
Comes in with that
20 second granularity
for the virtual environment.
Everything that we're bringing
in is encrypted to us.
It's anonymized.
Say deanonymized, but
it's anonymous to us.
So all we're looking at
is just an org identifier
and performance metadata.
No CPU, try no IP
addresses, Mac addresses
specific to most
of the assessments
unless that's something
you want to enable.
Now for the demo
side of it, I'm going
to tell you a little bit
what we're going to do.
We're going to go through
and we're going to--
by default, the partners
usually have invited a customer
into the platform already.
So that first step, you will
actually receive an email.
You'll log into the portal.
And the first activity you
will do is deploy our observer.
It's very quick.
It's a download.
There's no VA or OVF.
Powers it up or set up the
connections into your cloud.
If you want to add other
users, that's great.
All right.
The assessments in
the platform, there's
hundreds and hundreds
of analytics.
We categorize these
things into assessments.
And assessments
in this case, this
is the GCP and Intel assessment.
They've gone through
and chose what
characteristics that
were meaningful for them
to put into this review.
So as a platform,
there's a free edition
and there's a premium edition.
But, in the terms
of the assessments,
all the analytics that are
related to the assessment
are provided and funded
by Google and Intel.
What we're going to have here
is in terms of the analytics
are individual reports.
These are what we break
out into our cards.
Cards like vCenter
summary actually giving us
a collaborative view of
what resources are currently
in our data center.
Host analysis--
what hardware's end
of life, what
should be refreshed,
as well as guest
operating systems.
Really this really
gives us a foundation
as that trusted advisor
as a partner or for Google
to see the resources and make
a recommendation as we go.
I'm going to start here
with that universal view.
And before we actually make
the migration to the cloud,
it's worth noting
what do we have.
Are we looking at one cluster,
multiple data centers,
multiple campuses, multiple
networks and resources.
This is really more
so for everybody
to get into agreement as to
what resources are out here.
Really just set the tone of
did we actually go out and look
at the right environment.
Back us up.
Host analysis offers two
functionalities for us.
Give us an idea of the
resources that you have
and how you've deployed
them, see the hardware.
We can identify resources
that potentially could be end
of life like we talked about.
This opportunity to
go through and say,
you know what, I've got a large
number of servers in my data
center, but I'm
considering whether or not
I should go to 6.7.
So let's do a quick look
in the infrastructure
and find out how many hosts are
not compatible with vSphere 6.7
or 6.5 in this case.
And I see in this organization
there are 46 hosts out there
that are not compatible with
that release of the hypervisor.
Now this is an
inflection point for us.
Do we decide to
replace the hardware
and upgrade and buy
new hypervisor licenses
or is this really the
opportunity for us
to move that infrastructure
to the cloud?
So as this works as
a narrative for us,
we'll go through
and build this up.
Stepping back.
Find my arrow.
There we go.
Guest operating
system analysis really
is the on premise workload.
So when we're looking
at either the cloud
or we're looking at the
virtual infrastructure,
these are the resources
that you currently
have inside the
infrastructure that
are virtualized and deployed.
We see them as they're
configured, the resources
they're consuming.
We see the age and end of life
for some of these operating
systems.
So maybe there's opportunity
to move some of this
to a new version of Windows,
for example, high as well
as what aren't going to be
candidates for cloud migration.
We're going to
see things in here
like ESX, vSphere
running as a nested VM.
Maybe we see the Mac OS.
We'll go through and
clarify and identify
resources that are not going
to be cloud candidates.
Now most organizations need to
start working on the workflow
and managing the content.
So we break this
out to some degree
based on all the metrics
that are important to you,
whether it be clusters, or
hosts, or organizations,
or logical containers
and resources, data
stores, security groups,
state OS family and such,
as well as the ability to
go through and tag these
individually.
So I may want to tag
a subset of these
as production, staging, DevOps.
We do some automatic tagging
through the infrastructure.
We'll pull tags from vCenter
if they already exist.
If you are doing
application collection,
we'll apply the application
identity for that VM
and start doing some
application based tagging,
as well as guest
processes, so if you
are looking at certain resources
inside of the resources
as well.
Now, we can use this
to tag and manage it
down to a minimum subset
of resources that might
want to move to the cloud.
So we can tag individually
and see multiple tags.
I have a couple of
them already out here.
And we're going to use
that in just a second.
Got to figure out which
monitor is easier to see.
Ultimately, before we
make the cloud migration,
there's a portion of this
that is quick costing.
I want to do a quick
estimate to find out
whether this is a go or no go.
The effort to go through and
identify hardware and services,
resources in the data
center, quantify up early
and figure out is there
an opportunity for me
to move these resources
takes two parts.
What does it cost me on
premise and what is it
going to cost me in the cloud?
We do some on premise
cost simulations.
There's a lot of attributes
that you can go through
and tune through this as
well, but the top level ones,
cost of hardware, cost of
storage, cost of memory,
cost of licensing and support,
cost of third party services
as well as staffing and
resources like that, our power
and cooling, lots of
attributes and variables
we'll go through and touch on.
But what's nice
is as we quantify
a total cost of the
data center, we'll
actually take those
and apply that
to every one of the workloads.
And the end result
is for each workload,
we'll quantify as a
percentage of the entire data
set what is it using in terms
of storage and compute, memory.
And we'll give you a cost per
workload as it is configured.
Let's see if I get my
mouse on top of that.
I can't see from my angle.
There we go.
Cost of storage,
cost to compute,
giving you an overview.
We do some right sizing.
We can talk about some cost
avoidance and some summary
details of the infrastructure.
Now, what's nice is that
we have all the metrics
and all the data was collected
from the infrastructure, all
the IOps, all the throughputs,
all the contentions.
All that data is known
for us behind the scenes.
So we can actually go and do
exports and CSV and derivatives
where views of other cards to
actually give you some more
information on your migration.
Once we've got our
costs, the second part
is what's our cloud cost.
Costing for the cloud's
a little bit easier.
Choosing a geography, choosing
whether we want preemptive,
if we want reserved
instances, we want a one year,
two year commit, three
year commit storage
and geography are going
to be the easy ones.
But the one that
throws people off
is this idea of right sizing.
Obviously, every
application owner
is going to ask for as
many resources as possible.
If they can get 64 CPUs
and a terabyte of RAM,
they're going to ask for it
whether they need it or not.
But ultimately what
we're going to see
is what was the
actual utilization.
Where did they peak out in terms
of their actual utilization day
to day?
And was there an opportunity
for right sizing that?
How did they perform 99% percent
of the time or 95th percentile
and using those as guidelines.
Because we may see a
peak out there at 100%,
but it may be very short lived.
It could've been a
Windows reboot, an update.
Maybe it was the backup
window or something
happening inside the OS.
So going through and
letting you drill in
and looking at actual metrics
for individual resources
are available to us.
So we can go look at
per hour or per second,
see the type of activity that
we have had during the day.
In this case, a single VM here.
Can't see it's in here
how many CPUs that was.
CPU and performance.
Two CPUs.
Used 1 and 1/2 CPUs worth
of performance at its peak.
Do we right size for
that level knowing
that that was a one time
event or was it something
that happened over the course
of the day multiple times?
And, as we start
looking over the course
of a week or a month, we
can get into lots of detail.
We see that that short
lived spike is very short
lived universally.
It's not something that we're
worrying about for our day
to day production.
As we've gone
through the platform,
we've gone through and
seen the resources.
We've seen the hosts.
We've seen the VMs.
There's that pricing for GCP.
We've quantified
what the cost was.
We can also take that live data
from the cloud providers, AWS,
feed it into the
platform, and give you
that AWS to GCP migration
opportunity as well
with the right sizing, the
performance, and the analytics,
and the cost.
Knowing that a resource
was a 3x large on AWS
ends up being a custom
sized resource on GCP.
And we'll tell you
specifically what
the customization would be.
We'll do the direct matching.
Our analytics that comes
in for the matching,
we actually update from the API
directly from Google every day,
so we'll match out all
the current instances
and geographies and costs.
So we'll model that resources
for you as well as showing you
that option even for
GCP, maybe giving you
the option to cut some
costs by right sizing down
to that 99th percentile,
taking several hundred
thousand dollars out of
your monthly or annual bill.
Now again this is one
for one type activity.
We do offer a
complete view if you
have multiple clouds
in your assessment
the ability to go
through and look
at what would be the
cost for choosing
the same geography,
same storage,
changing different
configurations or attributes.
What will it be for
those different clouds?
Azure and Hyper-V,
AWS, GCP, or on prem--
where is my advantage going
to be in my cloud migration?
Now some clarification here.
We are looking at
the entire data set.
What you really
want to do is focus
this is on a per migration
or per resource level
and go through and
take those attributes
and make an
intelligent decision.
So we talked about
resources that we
may have tagged earlier.
I have resources
that were candidates.
And just looking at my subset
of resources out there,
these are really the only
candidates that I tagged.
As a whole, saving money
from as configured down
to that right sizing,
taking some slack out
of the environment, saving
us additional $300,000
through that process.
For the rest of us, if
we're not very technical,
you're in the sales or you're
in a management position,
you potentially are going to
come in and say, you know,
that was all great and dandy
but I have an architect team
to do that.
I just want the output.
We'll go through and actually
generate the reports for that
as well.
Actually, one item I skipped
here, AWS billing visibility.
If you do keep
content in AWS and you
want to go look at the
costing, today we'll
show you the exact
cost of the resources
that you're consuming for
bandwidth, inbound, outbound,
snapshots, all the subsystems
there, and then as well
comparison into GCP.
But let's take a time here.
Wizards for those of you that
aren't familiar with the cards
and don't want to get
too much detail into it,
we'll guide you
through the wizards
and generate out those reports.
Again, the type of thing
that management really
wants as a baseline,
the type of things
that you would typically
do for a larger service.
These are available to you
very quickly without ever
having to have a consultant
on site or service engagement.
If you've done the
deployment of the appliance,
this type of visibility is
going to come back to you,
allowing you to have the
results here within a few days.
Ultimately, we recommend
going this the full week.
We want to see the peaks.
We want to see weekends.
We can run it
longer, a full month.
And what's nice is
the cloud observer
can be left in the organization.
And you can run this
weekly, monthly, quarterly,
and do an annual
comparison as you've
gone through that
migration effort,
costing out what's on
premise, costing out
what's in the cloud.
And with that, I'm going
to pass over to Karl.
KARL KOSHY: So we're going
talk a little bit almost
as we follow through from
where Chris left off.
We're going to talk a
little bit about StratoZone,
the platform itself,
what it helps you do.
So StratoZone is
a purpose built,
born in cloud platform designed
entirely to take your risk
and help you overcome challenges
in the cloud migration space
or in the process of
planning your migration
as an organization as well as
executing on your migrations.
So, as we go through
this, one of the things
you'll see that minimizing
risk is a big thing for us.
Right.
So what are the biggest risks
in the cloud migration space?
One of the risks--
one of the risks is around
not knowing your environment.
So environment discovery
is super important.
Very scalable
environment discovery
helps you get through
thousands of workloads
in a very short period of
time and, most importantly,
from there what
it's going to let
you do is actually map
those workloads globally
on a global sync.
If you've got data centers
in multiple locations,
you've got data centers
in multiple countries,
it doesn't matter.
Pull everything together.
And the other big risk
that customers face today
is around the requirements.
Your risks around your
requirements stem from the fact
that a cloud strategy
has to be based
on your CFO's priorities, your
organization's priorities,
and, most importantly,
your best way
to get the return on investment
from a cloud strategy.
And when you put those
two things together,
one of the things that
we do as a platform is
we're going to get your
consumption velocity moved up.
And why do you need your
consumption velocity moved up?
One of the biggest
challenges we've
seen over thousands and
thousands of workloads being
moved to the cloud
is that when you're
straddling both
sides of the fence,
you're still part
private and you slow down
in your consumption
into cloud, you
are going to end up with an
extra cost, because you're
straddling both sides.
Your resources have
to be doubled up.
Your facilities have
You can't exactly shut
down a data center
so your footprint still remains
out there, power cooling,
so on and so forth.
So there's a lot
around the risk factors
that you have to take
into consideration.
So our entire goal is to help
you accelerate that consumption
cycle.
So most importantly,
what StratoZone
does outside of
the risk mitigation
is getting you to understand
what goes where and when.
Once you get that, you can put
a roadmap together very easily.
The challenge in
getting there is if you
don't have that roadmap--
what we call a
consumable roadmap
has to be realistic
and consumable.
It's the biggest missing
piece in most customers' cloud
planning.
So once you get a
consumable roadmap, that's
what goes where and when.
What is the delivery model?
What am I consuming with
platform as a service?
infrastructure as a service?
What stays private?
What can move to the cloud?
Right.
So basically, we call
that the delivery model.
How are you going to deliver
cloud to your organization?
And the implementation model.
Are you going to implement
cloud across all your assets
or are you going to stay with
just a few assets that will end
up going into the cloud, right?
So really having a
good grip on that
is the biggest priority
for most of our customers.
Now, of course, the platform
will pick for you the best fit
products.
And then we address
the largest risk area.
Is the return on investment
actually going to be there?
Am I actually saving
money going to cloud?
The platform we'll pick
the products for you.
It'll load it for you.
And most importantly, it's
going to give you probably
the most powerful pricing
engine to go and look at cloud
products, compare them to
private data center benchmarks,
and make sure that
you're actually
saving money going into cloud.
Not every use case
may work for you.
And those use cases
that do work for you,
you have to be able to
justify that up and sideways
in the organization.
So what do we do for you there?
In the TCO, ROI in
the financial space,
we have a benchmark
private data center.
It's certified.
It avoids you having
to pick your own costs
for the organization
and go find your costs.
If you do want to bring
your own costs to the table,
we can incorporate
those and you'll
have your own customer data
center which is customized.
But either way we
need a left side
to compare the right side to.
Right.
We need your private data
center costs in order
to compare that to the cloud.
So when you start looking at
how detailed you get in there,
we fundamentally can produce
the level of CFO business
case for you that lets you
go up in the organization
and make the justification
to move to cloud.
Now, a lot of times people
say it's a no brainer.
Push a couple of buttons.
You get there.
When you start talking to
your C-suite and your CFO,
the level of detail they want
is a lot more complicated.
So our business
cases handle things
like depreciation cycles,
fixed costs, sunk costs,
so on and so forth.
So just being prepared
with that is important.
And then the other, like I said,
the big important thing here
about making sure you
know what you're doing
is a consumable roadmap.
That consumable roadmap has to
have small enough pieces that
can be executed
and can be executed
in a successful manner.
As Tad was saying earlier, you
want to pick success stories
and then build on those success
worries as your organization
morphs into cloud.
And that's what the consumable
roadmap is designed to do.
Start out with small successes
and move to the next steps.
And then, the last thing here,
a predictable migration cost.
That's one of the biggest
shortcomings of cloud migration
plans.
Planning is great.
When you go to
migrate, you don't
know what those costs are.
And it can mess up your
return on investment.
And then at that point,
your accountability's
questioned around
the whole strategy.
So, on a technical level, for
those who are technical here,
this is a 10,000 foot
view, inventory analysis
down to the performance
capacity percentiles,
all the usual
things you'd expect
that anybody would require
in order to make a good sound
decision and how you're going
to consume cloud requirements
definition.
Most importantly, cloud fit
analysis, a very quick ability
to see what's a good
fit for cloud, what's
not a good fit, what your
remediation requirements are,
and how much work
you're going to have
to do to get those workloads
or those applications
into the cloud.
Right.
Application mapping
and dependency mapping,
two of the most
important risk areas
that everybody runs into,
not necessarily on day one
but down the road.
So that's one of the
other capabilities
around the platform
is to be able to do
very accurate application
and dependency mapping.
And one of the big ones
I like to point out
over thousands and thousands
of workloads we found out
that about 32% of
our customers' assets
are essentially being
kept on or the lights
are on for the
purposes of archive.
Customers don't know
what to do with it.
They can't get rid of it.
So data state analysis lets you
take those expensive archive
type assets and put those into
cold or warm storage, which
is probably about we
calculated out about a 1/50
of the cost of running a
data center space to keep
that data in place.
Right.
So one of the things
we've done as well,
we looked at the speed to which
the StrataZone platform helps
you get to your
decisioning points.
Our business case runs
about three to five days
once you do data discovery.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
And our entire plan
is usually done
in about four to five weeks.
That is all the way to what's
called a trigger ready state,
including application
mapping and all of the pieces
that go with that, including
a migration runbook that you
would need in order to get
from point A to point B.
So how do you get started?
Again, to a pointer
from earlier,
Google has licensed the platform
so it's available to customers
for free.
You fill up a form.
The form asks you to tell
us about your data center
environments.
Those environments are
important because we'd
like to know how you
want your data rolled up.
So once you fill
in that form, it'll
workflow to you a series
of data collectors
that are uniquely
numbered and tagged.
And what those
data collectors do
is that they report into
the platform with the way
you want to see your data.
So it could be EMIA, you know
North America, data center one,
data center two.
It doesn't matter.
We pretag data.
It's very important for
us, very important for you,
because the level of
automation gives you reports
starting the next morning.
Right.
You're going to start
seeing reports come in.
And we'd like to see them tagged
the way you want to see them.
So 30 minutes to install
a data collector.
You can start looking at
results in a couple hours.
We'd like to do at least
one day of data pulls.
The longer you let it run,
the better the data looks.
Right.
And the most
important thing here
is that, let's say
you're a retailer
and you have something that
you want to check in November
or you have an end
of month process.
You can schedule
the data collectors
to kick off again at the end of
the month, or end of the week,
or whenever that anticipated
peak period is going to be.
So that is the
extent of the work
you to start doing an
assessment in your environment.
Right.
It's 30 minutes per collector.
You install it.
You let it run.
After that, you're pretty
much working on all your data
and getting all of the
advanced deliverables
that we can produce for you.
So what I'd like to do is
talk a little bit for a second
about security.
It is a SaaS platform.
All of the data we're collecting
is entirely metadata related.
It's not application data,
not user data, nothing
that falls under any
regulatory requirements.
So there's no
issues around HIPAA
or anything from
that perspective.
And most importantly, we
have that conversation
with your CSOs,
your security folks.
If they want to ask
questions, there's
a security white paper
that's available to them.
Talks about every
field we collect.
And what's really
neat is that they
can inspect the actual
JSON files before they're
transmitted into their portal.
So you can see every single
field we're collecting
and validate that what
we said we're collecting
is what you're seeing
being transmitted.
And everything's encrypted
in transit, encrypted
at rest, all the usual things
that you would typically
expect.
But on top of all
of that, what we
have is the ability
to custom anonymize.
So if a specific customer says,
I don't want my IP addresses
going into your cloud, your 192
is the same as my 192 range,
but let's say you don't
want it in the cloud.
You can actually select
the degree of anonymization
that you'd like to
see in the platform.
Right.
So you can go all the
way to every piece
of identifiable
data being removed
or you can just have a
couple of things removed.
Rarely happens, but the features
and capabilities are there.
So last but not
least, once you've
done all that great planning,
StratoZone as a platform
goes from end to end.
We're going to help you with
your business case, your data
analysis.
We're going to help you
put all of your plan
together, build roadmaps.
And we'll talk about
roadmaps in a second.
Once you've built all
of that, you really
need to leverage that
in your migration plan.
One of the biggest
downfalls of migration plans
is that a great plan was done,
but then the migration plan
ends up being done
by a different team,
different party, and it's
completely different.
So here we actually carry all
of your planning and leverage
your investment and
the previous work
you did into the actual
migration process.
And we integrate with
Velostrata for GCP.
And it will automatically
build that runbook for you
and actually move
the assets into GCP
when you're looking at
doing a VM migration.
So it's a very smooth process.
You get a single pane
of glass to control
your entire migration process.
And what happens there is that
the business units that you
work with are also,
at the end of the day,
their process becomes smoother.
And so they're more
likely to participate
when you can show them
that you have an organized
way of getting their assets
migrated into the cloud.
Here's a quick example of
a process we went through.
Our partner at
Maven Wave, customer
eHarmony started data collection
of roughly 3,000 assets
on a Friday.
The whole business case was
ready presented on a Wednesday.
Right.
So you've got a lot
of analytics that
go around the business case.
And you can get to see
all of those details
from dependency
mapping, the business
case at the executive level,
the fully loaded TCO ROI.
So it really is not
just a compute, storage,
and memory kind
of business case.
It is a fully loaded
business case including
the cost of transition.
And that's what the
platform will produce in
literally 24 hours to three
days depending on how long you
want to let the data run.
So at this point, we're going
to jump into the platform real
quick and do a demo.
So StrataZone as a platform
is-- we'll reduce that size.
There we go.
It's a SaaS platform.
What you see as a customer
is what your partners see.
And it's also what your
deployment folks see.
It is completely transparent.
Pricing engine is
completely transparent.
Everything's available to you.
Kicking off an
assessment is very easy.
It's basically a quick
form that you kick off
once you get access.
You do an automated
asset discovery.
And all we need is who we're
going to email that one to.
So assessments in general.
You can have multiple
assessments globally.
You can pull all
this data together.
It does all of that
global sync for you,
but we'd like to know where
your data is coming from.
That's why you see
multiple assessments
globally in multiple locations.
Once you deploy those
data collectors,
that's the end of any
work you do as a customer
or as a partner.
Everything comes
into the platform.
It's maintained here.
And you can sort and filter
through your different areas.
But, most importantly,
what we're
capturing-- this module, by the
way, runs entirely on its own.
What we're capturing
for you is we're
getting all of your
performance stats.
We're profiling your assets.
If you notice as
they come in, you'll
see here you've got
all of your IOps
and your performance
metrics, everything
that's important to you
to do your right sizing
and your pricing.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
But our optimization engine
is extremely sophisticated.
We call it the truth serum.
A lot of our customers
will go to cloud
and they'll come back and say
I used the TCO calculator.
Cloud's more expensive
than my data center.
Once they go through
this platform,
we've challenged
every assumption
and we've fed them very
realistic data center
costs from our
benchmark data center
and we can actually prove
a very, very solid business
case around it.
So, again, all your
data is coming in.
All those things you see on
the left, the usual suspects,
CPU utilization, memory
utilization, all of that's
coming to the platform.
We've processed
your dependencies.
But, more importantly,
at this early stage--
these are day two
reports by the way--
at this early stage,
you can come in here
and see what gets a high,
medium, and a low scoring
for the cloud.
And your first question
is going to be,
well, why did I get a
high, medium, or a low.
And it actually creates
your remediation plan
and shows you with multiple
reasons like your credit report
why you got a high,
medium, or low.
So, if you look
through this process,
every single thing has been
scored for you automatically.
And you can actually give
the system some priorities
and say this is important to me.
That's not important to me.
It's not important that
I'm able to exit the cloud,
or I don't want my high
performance compute
assets going to the cloud.
So, once you do this, your
scoring actually changes.
But the whole idea here is
based on your priorities
we're giving you a very, very
solid machine based score that
shows you, with the
underlying reasons,
why you're a good fit for
the cloud or you're not.
And, at this point, there's
lots of reports available.
This is what we call
our day two reports.
You've got all your detailed
reports that the data center
folks would like.
There's a bunch of
executive reports.
But you can actually
come in here.
The platform's
automatically right
sized you and done
all the optimization.
You can come in here, pick
your different locations,
and generate a ROI calculation
right off the bat, basically
an ROI, a savings calculation.
And you can pick one or
more product catalogs
that you want to see it from.
Now, typically, we
make the other catalogs
available in the
Google ecosystem.
So you may want to actually
see what your comparative costs
looks like.
Right.
But it's all real time catalogs.
And they will present
you with the results
that you can actually
take to your leadership
and walk the cloud plan around.
And to show you really quick
what that cloud plan looks
like, it is going to
be a executive level
presentation that
talks about what
we did for the assessment, what
we looked at at a high level,
and what we found.
I'll skip right to
the bottom line.
Ultimately, it's
going to get down
to an explanation of how we
did your financial costing
and a business case to start
the conversation about moving
to cloud.
This is available
the next morning.
Right.
We'd like to have
24 hours of data.
We can pull it in three
hours, but it's available
next morning.
So you've got a business case.
You've got a very
solid determination.
And this is based on
reality data underlying
this, performance capacity,
and an actual real time catalog
comparison.
So, from here, I'd like to
show you a little bit more
sophisticated functionality.
We won't get too much on it.
I've got four minutes left.
So one of the big
things here, we
have a very, very
sophisticated approach
to doing machine shaping.
And that is your paradigm
today of buying hardware
and resourcing a data
center is based on capacity.
The paradigm in the future
is based on elasticity.
You've got the ability to scale
up and down as you see fit.
So you need to change how
you're going to think.
Again, speaking of the truth
serum, once we go through this,
you're going to be
able to take out
all of the inefficiency in
your current environment
and then see what your real
cloud costs are going to be.
That's really important, because
if you do a one to one match,
you're simply taking your
inefficiency into the cloud.
So this machine shaping
panel, we do it.
A lot of the GCP ecosystem
partners will do it for you.
But ultimately, it's
going to let you
shape your life in the cloud.
Very important.
From here, you'll see that the
pricing engine will give you
the ability to go
through and really do
some skilled analysis.
Right.
So if you're looking here on
the different pricing engines,
I'm going to be able to go
in and see exactly what it
picked for me and how it meters
to what I have on prem today.
And it's full
disclosure, so you're
going to see every single
costing factor that built up
that pricing, including
how many hours
we're buying for you if
it's an on demand catalog.
And you've got the ability
to look at the committed use
catalogs.
It's got all the sustained
use capabilities built in.
All the discounting's built in.
You can get custom
discounting if you're
a large customer that needs it.
But, at the end of the day,
you're able to come in here
and do a very realistic
assessment of what
your world looks like from
comparing the private data
center benchmark or your data
into any of the GCP catalogs,
for example, to
see your savings.
Very quick, and this is based
on actual real information
from your assets
underlying the platform.
And then here you'll see one
of the most important things
customers really like
about the platform.
It gives you the ability
to go in and look
at your dependency maps.
It's processed your
dependencies for you.
It's going to throw these
dependencies up on a screen.
It's cleaning them for you.
It's taking out the
data center noise.
And when I blow
this up, you'll see
that it's actually telling you
how all your assets communicate
with each other.
This is cleansed, so it's
taken out your AD DNS
noise, all the stuff that's
your usual monitoring
stuff from your data center.
And what it's got for you is
a very clean dependency map.
This is a business server
somehow typed together,
so you cannot break this
map when you migrate.
This is the biggest risk area in
a customer transition to cloud.
How am I going to
break my dependencies?
I don't even know
my dependencies.
So first, understanding
your dependencies,
knowing what you're
doing with them,
and seeing whether or not
you're going to break those
dependencies.
And, at the end of
the cycle, you're
able to build out a roadmap.
The roadmap is probably the
most important thing here.
We will deliver a
consumable cloud roadmap.
What that means it's going
to have multiple roadmaps
and multiple waves.
And you can come in here
and say pretty much anything
you want to the platform.
You can come in
here and say show me
everything that's the dev
version of my ERP application
that has an asset age over
so many years, and by the way
it belongs on a certain subnet,
and has a server role of dev,
or anything you want.
You can say show me my
Windows 2003 that's going
to go into an end of life wave.
So once you build your
roadmap, you can figure out
how to empty out that
entire data center
and you can move
things around to get
to that return on
investment the way you
want to see it from a
financial perspective
and not make this a
data center exercise.
So, with that, I'll stop
here and pass the mic back.
TAD EINSTEIN: So, in closing,
how does Google actually
help you succeed
and most importantly
at no additional cost?
And this was mentioned.
So, through our partnership
through Cloud Physics
and StratoZone, you can
actually partner with us
and we will pay
for this assessment
so Cloud Physics and
StratoZone can actually
deliver it on site.
You can do it yourselves.
You can leverage
one of our partners.
But the licensing is
fully covered by Google
so you can actually get started
right away getting visibility
into your environment, making
a strong business case.
Sometimes it's not even that.
Sometimes it's just
verifying the business case
to see if what
you did previously
is the right way to go.
And one of the great parts
that was mentioned too
is allowing these tools to run.
When I was a customer, I would
let these tools run, sometimes
around let's say end
of month when we're
running our quarterly reports.
And it really helped a lot
with our capacity planning.
So it's more than
just right now.
It's also in the future to have
these tools running, giving you
the right visibility.
So, in closing, I'd like to
say it's easy as 1, 2, 3.
But that being said,
as you remember,
we talked about the GCAF
first, which is Google Cloud's
Adoption Framework.
It's a white paper.
I recommend everyone
download that, take a look,
and have a talk within your
company about these things.
You're going to get a solid
understanding of where
you currently are and also the
action items that are going
to be needed for next steps
to migrate to the cloud
or really to any environment
as you move forward
on your journey.
After you understand the
GCAF, you have your strategy
in place.
Then engage Google, engage
StrataZone, Cloud Physics.
Let us come in, help you
with a no cost assessment,
leveraging these best of
breed tools to really get you
the insight you need.
And then, finally, you actually
can leverage that insight
to deploy and to migrate.
So, as you might have
seen, the products
directly integrate
with Velostrata,
which is our migration tool.
So you can go from
understanding your ROI
TCO to putting
together move groups,
understanding how
everything's connected,
and then ingesting that
directly into the migration tool
to get into Google Cloud.
And then, from there, you
can optimize, maybe go
into Kubernetes, and take
it to the next level.
[MUSIC PLAYING]